miles is with us miles is in
wichita kansas hey miles how can we help
hi mr ramsey it's an honor and pleasure
to speak with you today
you too what's up well
uh i would like some advice from you on
uh
some purchase opportunities that i've
got to
buy at home and with some
aspects to my life i'm wondering if i
should pay cash for it
or if i should try and get a mortgage or
or get a loan
i've i pretty much got the cash to pay
for it but as a christian i'm wondering
if
i should because i've got the chance to
do that if i should go and do it or
because of the convenience if i should
just go ahead
and get a mortgage on it
i'm the the biggest stickler to my
life aspect is i'm 20 years old and
i go to school part i work full-time
with my dad and i've got two or three
businesses besides that
and i'm wondering is is bringing up
uh some of the cash for capital for what
i do smart or should i try and
um to keep it um available
for my businesses or should i just put
all that capital
into that house and uh and keep it there
and then just slowly
so much money do you have saved
uh right around 100 000 and you're 20
years old
yes sir how'd you do that
i worked hard i've been extremely
blessed
my parents are very wise
and raising me in a way to be debt-free
work hard
i took your ramsey
course through high school and just as a
general
attitude to life you know knowing
everything is god's and knowing
everything
that i've got is not mine and just
managing it as well as just
keeping my expenses low and saving where
i can you're amazing
that's incredible so what uh uh what
kind of income are you earning a year
between all these things you're doing so
i don't specifically have a lot of
income like i said i work with my dad
full time
my first real every year of work and
income that i got from him was pretty
much just last year a year and a half i
took home about 30 000
um and then probably between all the
other stuff i do it's around ten
thousand dollars
um so where did 100 come from again
just pretty much
pretty much just saving i mean ever
since ever since i've been young
um i i mow lawns i've been doing that
since i was 12 or 13.
um you know like i said just being very
blessed and just like i don't spend a
lot of money
do you live with your mom and dad still
yes i do
and that's that's another um aspect of
it as 20 as i'm 20 years old i'm going
to school part-time as well
so i'm looking to buy this house as a
rental
and then when i graduate in a couple
years try and try and move into it as my
own house
no i would not buy a house
you think that's the wise place to be i
think the wise thing to do is for you to
finish school
before you worry about before you work i
would not get in the rental business
this is the don't get in the rental
business while you're in college
yeah so we didn't know it was but it is
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't put you in
the rental business while you're making
30 000
a year and trying to go through school
uh i don't mind you getting there
and you are you are an overachiever
you're an incredible young man
but let's not uh get confused about what
got us here it wasn't real estate
i love real estate and i want you to own
some real estate someday
i thought you were buying this house to
move into so
that that you know might have changed
the answer but i don't think it does
um i think you're going to continue to
pile up money and you go ahead and get
in school and get your button gear and
get finished
and when you graduate and you leave home
and you start your own life and you have
a pile of cash pay cash for your first
home that you're going to live in
then start talking about buying rental
property that you pay cash for
but i wouldn't get this out of order i
wouldn't get it backwards it's so
tempting too i'm sure miles because you
have this pile of cash you have a
hundred thousand dollars so you can
rationalize in your head while i have
this money so i should buy a house
you're living at home you're fine finish
out school just because you have the
money doesn't mean you have to spend it
just like we were saying earlier you're
in a transitional time in your life
what you need today is not necessarily
what you'll need or want in a year
or three years finish out school and
then make a decision
about your housing situation and your
money
yeah so with rare exceptions
if you never buy a piece of real estate
before you're 25 years old
it's not the end of the world including
your home yeah
i mean you can just move out and rent a
little apartment
and get your life started yeah uh this
idea that you have to move out
into a furnished home with a skylight
and a jacuzzi
um at 24 years old or 23 years old is
just
guys there's it's not talking down to
you because you're young
all i'm saying is just have a little
freaking patience well and one of the
things i heard the most
out of college dave and i've heard it a
million times is you're throwing money
away on rent you're throwing money away
on rent you hear it again and again that
is an oversimplified
statement on the situation what you're
buying is time
peace of mind someone else is dealing
with all the maintenance of the home
there's so much more that goes into home
ownership than just
the purchase price of the house and i
think a lot of young people don't
consider that they don't think about
a new ac unit or you need a new roof or
something goes wrong and all the
headache
that goes with it whether you're living
in it or not that
you may not want to turn being a renter
for 15 or 20 years is a bad idea being a
renter for 36 months
while you're going through some
transitional periods in your life like
leaving home for the first time those
kinds of things it's not dumb at all
yeah
it's not dumb at all renters don't go to
hell it's not a salvation issue
okay i mean you're not like done
something completely stupid where you've
ruined your whole life
because you're a renter for a little
while yeah um i've rented
um you know and i own a bunch of real
estate and i believe in real estate and
i want you to get some real estate
but real estate purchases as an
investment is
very unwise and will set you back
in your whole wealth building process it
will set you back
not push you forward if you do it before
you've done some of these other things
and so it is a late in the game late in
the baby steps
idea that you invest in real estate
uh because otherwise real estate will
kick you in the teeth and will move you
backwards in your wealth building
and so no you don't need to buy a rental
house when you don't have a house
that's paid for that you live in no you
don't need to buy a rental house
until you have graduated from college no
you don't need to buy a rental house
until you can pay cash for it
no you don't need to buy a rental house
until you're out of debt how own a home
have an emergency fund in place and it
paid off your home
no you don't need to buy a rental house
before you're 25
unless you're in a very very unusual
situation
now this young man here is pretty
incredible he's done some really cool
stuff but here's the thing dude
you buy a house right now with all that
money and you're not making but 30 grand
you don't have any money you gave up all
your money because if i thought you were
going to tell me in this business you're
making 100 000
a year or something i didn't know where
this money but this has been from 12
years old he saved
every cutting money yeah and that's how
you got here so you're a tremendous
saver
you are not yet a tremendous earner you
will be
i think just listening to you i think
you're incredible i think you're going
to be a big place when you're but when
you're making 60 or 80 000 or 180 000 it
makes the
this equation completely different
and that's where you're going to be when
you graduate with your four-year degree
and you have your full-on career
and you're doing stuff because you're a
dude that gets stuff done yeah but just
be it's okay
just take it just breathe just breathe
you're you're not gonna you're not
you're not gonna die you're not you're
not stupid you're not um
throwing money away to rent for 36
months
from your 22nd birthday to your 25th
birthday it's not it's just not the end
of the freaking world
and that includes those of you getting
married she wants to buy a house or he
wants to buy a house i don't give a crap
you're broke
when broke people buy houses you get
broker and that's why they call them
real estate
brokers that's where that comes from so
and i've done that
and lots of people have done that and
we've seen the strain and the coaching
over the years
you know we you and i have both seen it
over and over and over again yeah